encore
méconnu du grand public david card est
une sommité dans son domaine l'étude du
marché du travail le canadien qui
enseigne à l'université berkeley en
californie est l'un des trois
récipiendaires du nobel d'économie un
prix qui le laisse sans mon
jeu je n'ai pas grand chose à dire
lance-t-il tout sourire avant de
remercier ses collègues des villes corde
est notamment récompensé pour les
travaux sur le salaire minimum qui l'a
mené en compagnie du regretté alain
kruger secrétaire adjoint au trésor sous
barack obama au début des années 90 les
deux chercheurs évaluent l'impact d'une
hausse modérée du salaire minimum au
new-jersey et conclu qu'elle ne m'aime
pas des pertes d'emplois un constat
alors contesté
à l'époque ses conclusions étaient
controversées explique-t-il plusieurs
économistes étaient plutôt sceptiques de
nos résultats au cours de sa carrière
david card s'est aussi intéressée aux
effets de l'arrivée d'immigrants sur le
marché du travail et à la corrélation
entre les revenus et le niveau
d'éducation
ce
travail suppose seulement un chercheur
qui cherchent un chercheur qui trouvent
des réponses la proche de l'expérience
naturel utilisé par david card c'est à
dire en analysant des phénomènes
concrets sur le terrain a laissé sa
marque et influence les économistes
d'ici et d'ailleurs on est imprégné de
philosophie la prochaine qui sont
particuliers on va réfléchir à des
situations l'expérience actuelle salut
les normes
neagu elf en ontario david card a reçu
un doctorat honorifique de l'université
de montréal il y a deux ans il partage
le nobel d'économie avec l'américain
josh wink grist et le néerlandais guido
mbs deux autres pionniers de
l'expérience naturel et se livrer
bachand radio canada montréal
[Musique]